that's like watching a Japanese death
match with no storytelling right just
just violence yeah the sake of violence
yeah hey what's going on everybody for
first we Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Mick Foley he's a
WWE Hall of Famer a writer who's made
multiple appearances on the New York
Times bestseller list and you can keep
up with him these days on the f is POD
podcast and YouTube channel but today
the hardcore Legend takes on a battle
royale against the wings of death Mick
Foley welcome to the show thank you very
much Sean uh this comes highly
recommended by my children really yeah
yeah and as long as I mention the
children can I say uh I'm going the
vegan option for them me right along
with you before we get started though
how are you around hot sauce you get all
nervous going into this a little bit
because the man I think I am may not
turn out to be the man I
[Music]
am I have to take out my cell teeth oh
there we go these are the teeth that are
knocked out in the Cell match I know
you've had the Undertaker on here y all
right so I'm going to try this one first
right here we
[Music]
go
okay you're just saying it's going to
get progressively hotter from here yeah
this is base camp over here okay I'm
doomed okay let's
uh all right so I'm always interested in
the humble beginnings of a wrestler's
career in your case commuting 400 miles
to train with Dominic NCI living on a
diet of peanut butter and bread sleeping
in the back of your Ford Fairmont when
you think about the small towns that you
performed in from pocco West Virginia to
Freedom Pennsylvania is there a match
that stands out in your brain as being
just as compelling just as good as
anything you ever did on a pay-per-view
oh on those little ones well the nice
thing about those shows was that every
match was your most important match uh
ironically when I got to WWE there was
this feeling of looking out and saying
wow there's 18 ,000 people out tonight
and you know what there's going to be
another 18,000 tomorrow so although I
was not known as a guy who held anything
back I was holding a little something
back each night whereas like in Poca
there were 26 people there I remember
going all out just having this
incredible feeling of satisfaction it
didn't matter that I was spending more
on gas than I was making What mattered
is that we were working towards uh
towards a
dream this is okay this wouldn't be my
choice it's pretty good but
not just okay for you mhm yeah what's
the fully risk reward
analysis it's the instantaneous fully
risk reward ratio analysis that was I
think it was a god-given gift that would
tell me just you want a case in point
yeah yeah i' love one all right so uh
January 2000 just a few blocks away
Madison Square Garden uh I remember Mr
McMahon saying to me in Triple H you
know no some TX and then as soon as uh
Mr MCM man walked away Triple H looked
at me goes you put him under the ring
already yeah I got it taken care of this
is one of the last matches of my career
and so it was a big moment and I just
saw that Majestic you know pile there
were five 6,000 tax and I thought about
the wisdom of taking the pedigree face
first in those thumbtacks and I came to
the conclusion that okay I could lose an
eye but imagine the
[Laughter]
[Music]
pop this looks more my
style okay I'm skeptical yeah matches
the shirt a little bit
[Music]
Mi the Hawaiian a summer
flannel tropical vibe to this whole
thing you know like it I knew you would
can you talk me through the technique of
busting an eyebrow and then what are the
consequences of doing that maneuver
incorrectly you think that's going to
enrich your life if I tell you I'd love
to know I'd love to
know well you know the it's it's we're
in a better world as far as wrestling
goes you don't get the fake versus real
debate but you used to get that all the
time and um the most
believable and inexplicable to the
wrestling cynic would be the busted
eyebrow now the problem is if you just
punch somebody hard in the eye chances
are it's going to swell but not
necessarily open up so Robert Fuller who
was known by Tennessee Lee was one of
his names in WWE Colonel Parker in WCW
he was a third generation wrestler Jacko
it's not the fource and he taught me
it's cut it punching down it's like bam
so it's not boom it's boom catching an
angle you catch it in an angle and uh
there were old school guys who were
specialists in it so I was one of the
last of my generation to be like a
willing participant in what is a
terrible
practice the down upside is yeah it's
believable downside yeah you could go
blind uh in an ECW match against a guy
named Tommy dreamer Tommy inaccurately
believed that having been the
participant in some of these hard ways
made me an expert in giving them which I
was not and he wanted me to open them up
hard way so he wanted to go through the
things that I'd gone through and long
story short after about six punches
missed every hit everywhere in his face
except his eyebrow I don't care how
tough you are you get punched in the
nose you're going to bring tears to your
eyes right after about five Haymakers
that land anywhere and I'm trying to go
down try cat they're not hay makers
they're short but they're punches but
they're still I'm hitting him below the
eye and I'm hitting him in the nose and
the forehead and he's get welts in his
head and he finally looked up to me
through tears in his eyes and goes would
you please stop
[Music]
biting I like it a
lot favorite one so far I think so is
that are the original the original
Buffalo we'll take that can you give me
one highlight and one low light from
performing in Corian Hall in Tokyo
trying to think of a low light cuz I I
don't know do you know of a low light
have I spoken of a low light well I know
you know you're using like spools of
barb wire instead of uh the ring rope
and stuff like that sounds conclusion
that was a low light that for it would
have been for me Mick I know you're
built different you're built different
you know my my favorite bar bar match
from
Japan what a
sentence was actually not in corken Hall
but in a small um
prefecture uh outside of Tokyo called
Guma it was January 10th 1995 when Terry
Funk and I did things that would have
gotten us arrested in most countries in
the world and then in 2004 I did an
angle with Randy Orton we went back over
some of the stuff I'd done in Japan and
I saw saw he had my opponent in a back
breaker over his knee and I wrapped the
barb wire around my elbow arm and I came
off the ring apron with the elbow and as
I hit Rick Patterson flipped the guy it
looked
incredible and I and I looked up at that
camera and I went bang bang and I just
fast forwarding nine years now it's 2004
and I'm watching the video and I was
like you can Fain a lot of things you
cannot feain the look of utter Joy
that I had after I dropped that elbow on
sh nakamaki and I had to admit like okay
maybe there was part of me that like
being in there did not hate it so yeah I
I have some good memories it was it was
really treated respectfully you know
there was no vibe of like being uh you
know like an animal Behind Bars being
shouted out you when you're over there
it was really seen as a respectful
endeavor it's hot I'm going to give them
that it's
hot there you go and you're loving these
wings too it looks like I am right even
though it's hot going back in
respect Factor fiction the mankind
character is inspired in part by you
reading Mary Shell's classic novel
Frankenstein and listening to Tor Amos
yeah yeah a little bit yeah when I had
the uh character and then um you know Mr
rman have you heard your name yet this
is only like the third time I met him
and I actually had heard the name was
supposed to be Mason the mutilator which
I thought that's that's the death nail
of a career career right there so I had
a chance he goes he goes in this
business we've had Crushers we've had
destroyers we've had
executioners but we've never had a
mutilator and I look at him I said I
like it I like it a lot but what if and
what if were the two best words What If
instead of Mason I was mankind the
mutilator and I started telling him you
know it could be a double meaning the
destruction of mankind the future of
mankind and that's again going back to
Mary Shelly as the the creature who was
made Evil by Society not
necessarily created to be that way uh
and he took it all down and sure enough
when I debuted uh I wasn't there was no
mutilator it was just mankind and I'll
go on the record as go as I'll go so far
as to say it turned out to be pretty
worked out it worked out for it it
worked out I don't think I'm here as
Mason the mutilator I don't think so how
about this is it uh is it true that you
though muzzled you Wrestled a Bear in
1985 yeah I think my third ma my fourth
match in my career was against a bear
how'd that go not well uh they never go
well a bear is like 8 to 10 times
stronger than human being right mhm you
know the bear from Canada had killed a
person I mean that's a historical fact
but that's what we do we say we can do
things when we don't know if we can so I
didn't know the danger I was in I just
knew that I jumped on its back trying to
like turn into a show and the bear stood
up and threw me across the ring and
that's when I realized a bear was 8 to
10 times stronger than I was uh and I
laid down and let that bear defeat me I
was hum oh yeah humbled big time
all right whiskey smoke
ghost I like it I have a friend and
colleague named ODB who has a food truck
and she uses a Whiskey Whiskey sauce
it's really good on her barbecue that's
good and a little hot but no problem for
you I'm okay with it I think it's these
green things that kind of caught you
mhm so just kind of point out this is is
for my kids sake almond milk yeah I'm
actually going to join you at the party
over
here so in your documentary with A&E
there's a scene where you direct the
cameraman to shoot your flying elbow
from a lower angle so that it can truly
capture the depth appreciate the depth
of that flight is it typical for
wrestlers to direct their performances
with that degree of specificity it is
now it is now in that the producers will
seek out the wrestlers and and try to
get the best possible camera shot but I
was doing this move coming off the
camera uh coming off the ring
apron that I mean you guys see me walk
in right I struggle a little bit that's
largely because that one move was the
poorest skeletal choice I could possibly
just rattles you so there's nothing as
well there's more other things in life
more frustrating than missing a move but
I'm saying it is frustrating when you do
something big you go back to watch it
and it doesn't come across in the the
way you hoped it would that's that risk
reward there's got to be the reward got
to be got to be that doesn't explain why
I would do that stupid move on
non-televised House shows though right
but that's just because you know you're
a showman yeah I used to feel like you
know there might be two people out there
who Trel traveled 300 miles they deserve
to see me get hurt so I took that
[Music]
seriously I'm not feeling it there you
go maybe you're just in the clear I'm
kind of feeling it a little
[Music]
bit it's good but it doesn't have the
doesn't have the kick that
uh this power jab yeah yeah Power jab I
think so far that made me the most
uncomfortable how would you quantify the
influence of someone like Stanley
Sherman oh okay the mask maker he was a
master at his craft the mask was far
more intricate than people thought
thought but for my Cameo videos I wear a
knockoff that was made in Thailand and
for the life of me I can't really tell
the
difference when I contacted the young
man from Thailand he thought I was
trying to get him in trouble I was like
I just want to know the secret I want
you to make me a mask man yeah I I was
using those little Amazon rubber masks
so I'm pretty good uh yeah young man did
a nice job uh Thailand out to Thailand
thank you mask makers of Thailand all
right well this is the sauce makers of
Kansas City okay de bomb Beyond
insanity this one I think will catch
both of us Kansas City knows their
barbecue
[Music]
too be almost immediate oh yeah it is
immediate this is just outright cruel
wow
oh yeah oh that's like watching a
Japanese death match with no
storytelling right just just violence
yeah for the sake of violence
yeah and you're telling me these next
two could get
worse so potentially but Mick I'd never
lie to you yeah uh nothing is going to
be as bad as what you just ate ever
nothing will be as bad as what you just
ate ever trust me are you sure yeah yeah
that's a promise I have your promise to
that that's a
promise okay yeah can I remove this from
my site yeah yeah go ahead get it out of
here oh and then just be careful around
the eyes
yeah so I know that behind the Twisted
Persona of your professional career
there's really a kid at heart a
self-described roller coaster addict
someone who has a permanent room in
their house dedicated to Christmas I
know I know I know what makes the
Hallmark original movie Christmas at Ply
Mansion one of your most beloved films
of all
time ah I'm going to be honest it was a
good movie I think I had a pandemic
Crush going on on Jessica lowens I did
like it it was really really good story
but it's all about the chemistry right I
don't watch them as much as I used to
yeah he used to be into it I saw a blog
post where you ranked your topart
Christmas yeah and that's how you knew
about ply Manor yeah I had to go deep
for that
yeah PE it's a good one I I
think in retrospect maybe finding Father
Christmas was the controversy there at
the top maybe a little controversy yeah
yeah we all had those pandemic crushes
right right yeah yeah you're not alone
in this yeah some people turn to
drinking I went with long distance
unreasonable crushes yeah it was I went
from Jessica louns to Janice from
friends that's a hey Mick you're guy
with some range you're guy with some
range oh my God I go oh my God I love
you Janice if you're out there uh Maggie
wheeler and she did a cameo for me that
was Dynamite really yeah yeah so yeah I
wanted to have my own Janice shirt made
cuz I can do that through pro wrestling
te's you're man who connected with a
shirt that is oh my God so that's when
you know you've been indoors too long
when you start yearning for Janet from
Friends
oh God
okay you can tell I didn't NE take a
bite
okay we have this over the shoulder
cameras
too now not fun by any stretch but after
the last
one burns the lips for sure y now it's
burning my
esophagus it's stomach compound it's
it's compounding over it's not playing
well with the last one
either but we're almost the
Finish okay do you have an all-time
favorite Jim Ross
call oh you got to go I mean they're
great hidden calls and Jim's got a new
book coming out about his 50 greatest
calls in the stories behind them which
is should be a must read for any you
know dieh hard wrestling
fan but I
mean what say you're watching the world
cup and a team goes up three
nothing and you see Memes across the
globe that say enough's enough somebody
stop the damn match I mean it's a tie
with me between go God is my witness
he's been broken in half and enough's
enough would somebody stop the damn
match from the same match only a few
minutes apart I mean he was really in
the zone and it was great that he didn't
know about it so he was calling it as he
felt it and even if he does know
something you know might be happening
you know he is the ultimate professional
just does a great job bringing those
matches to
life but since uh I'm here as a WWE guy
Michel Cole do doing a good job too so
[Music]
they all right the last
D you know how I escaped the wing eating
contest how did you yeah how did you I
thought you could contend with like 40
to 50 Wings then I found out the woman
sitting next to me had won it with
470 and they're like they're just like
skin stretched over bone right they were
I mean I got through and they do them in
two like 15 minute rounds yeah yeah yeah
and I realize I take a pause during that
rest perod and I thought I'm going to
throw up I said I got to get out of here
catch me cheating and I could see when
the camera's on me and then I do I see
myself on the scoreboard I go like I'm
looking and I
go I like four wings in my fanny pack
and they came over and disqualified me
and then I did my best all everything in
my ability to act as shocked as I could
outraged i' actually been caught and I'd
say like 18 seconds after I was caught
cheating and thrown out of the Wing Bowl
I get a buzzer on my phone and I see
it's
TMZ and I go I think I'm still relevant
you know so that made news around the
world uh but this is a far more uh
fulfilling oh psychologically
emotionally spiritually all right is
that enough salce on there that's plenty
that's plenty that's
[Music]
plenty contemplative
yeah for $10 I'll chug this whole
bottle I can't do that to
you throw in the
towel
enough but the good news is we're done
this Inferno match our version of an
Inferno match we've survived it we've
conquered it and you know to close
things out is someone who's been an
ambassador to this thing what do you see
as your lasting influence on
wrestling I like to think I treated
people well I like think that was my
last impression because I remember
coming up through the ranks and not
being treated well and then I remember
big stars going out their way to be kind
to me and I
thought if I ever get to be in this
position that's the way I'm going to
treat people is I like how this feels so
I I that's the way I hope I'm remembered
you know I still uh my um one of my
hobbies I do about 40 handwritten
letters uh from Santa when I had my hip
and knee replaced in two different
operations in 2017 I really worked on my
handwriting and so I hope that uh people
remember like that guy from the cell
like he wrote my kid he's been writing
my kid letters from Santa for like s
years so that's honestly what I hope my
um my legacy is that I treated people
well well you know what the performance
today will only build on that Legacy M
buy coming in here doing the kids proud
taking on the wings of death living to
tell the tale and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life not
much just trying to make a quick Buck
off my name you no no no I
do if you want to know where I'll be in
the world real micoley.com and check out
the events page uh the cameos and um and
that's I believe all that I have going
on correct me if I'm wrong thank you
appreciate
it thank
[Music]
you get a little Santa in
there wait look I'm going to show you
and then your reaction will will tell
the tale whether or not this is Santa's
handwriting is that Santa's handwriting
oh my God that's you do that yeah that's
my hand y
boom hot ones fans it's been years in
the making but at long last the next big
thing in Wings is finally here
introducing hot ones buffalo sauce our
spin on Buffalo is a rich and tangy
combo of of cayenne peppers distilled
vinegar and yes real butter which means
that you can put hot ones buffalo sauce
directly on wings no mixing or melting
required it's the best damn buffalo
sauce I've ever had in my life but don't
take my word for it camera guy Bill
Buffalo's favorite song gives it to blaz
and thumbs up don't you Bill that's a
Buffalo Bill
guarantee heatness.com heatness.com
that's heatness to get your hands on the
brand new hot ones buffalo
sauce